hmm it's tough interesting question can
it can we clarify the question a little
bit more well I look for in a woman
so mmm that's tough I look for someone
cute someone who I can have fun with
someone who shares somewhat the same
interests I do and someone who
[Music]
I'm kind of introverted I like talking
to people that much someone I can be
lazy with that's what I like yeah what
do I look for did we just talk about
this you know I look for honesty and
somebody who has a sense of like what
they really actually care about like
what they're really out for in life and
someone who will follow through on their
dreams that's what I look for no I'm
pretty simple I like a just a simple
woman that's over minded and not
high-maintenance
so I do the answer is because I've asked
myself this question before and I
usually the body draws me in right like
it appeals and then I come to another
person and then the body just kind of
doesn't become as important anymore but
the actual person inside so yeah that's
just that's how it is
that's how I got made so I know that's
why I knew who was gonna marry she just
unconditionally accept him right like
understanding just brave and discipline
you know like just like a great example
of love that I hadn't felt since like my
grandmother and you know it's just like
that kind of level of love that you feel
from that for that person yeah and I
just I got that she has to be funny
looks are good yeah
but you really have to like connect with
them and like be a friend with them and
like what my girlfriend is we were
friends before we were friends for six
months before we became boyfriend and
girlfriend so it's all about the
connection I guess we do anything
specific that happened then and not
really I mean it was the same it was the
title of being boyfriend and girlfriend
but like we still acted the same and
we're still the same so we're just
friends that was raised around a lot of
women so I usually tend to go to someone
that's a little more independent kind of
a strong woman I would say and someone
that's I guess a little more not so
submissive type because that's how I was
raised really around women that are
pretty strong so that's kind of that
kind of tend to go for is those kind of
more that independent woman I guess I
just thought she was cool because most
girls I was afraid to talk to but she
was cool to talk to you
and I choose pretty she was awesome like
I liked her she I don't know I just
liked her features and stuff but the
main thing was she was awesome to talk
to and but me and her weren't going to
get married but because she didn't want
to be with someone she had already been
with someone who
that she was playing on getting married
and she asked me like she didn't to keep
dating if I wasn't willing to be commit
to her like to to be married and then I
actually got saved like about a day or
two later and I really feel like the
Lord was telling me to marry her and it
was it was really I just choose just an
awesome person I just loved her I it's a
hard question for me to answer like
exactly what I find woman because she
was really my first girlfriend so I
wasn't really like looking too much like
like her height or her her skin color or
anything I just I just wanted someone
who was like my friend and it'd be cool
to spend the rest of our life together
and so uh yeah so we got married yeah
obviously like the go to mainstream
answer is what's on the inside
personality all that stuff but
attraction wise I think I look at her
eyebrows and her teeth like those two
are on point it's a winner for the most
part and then have actually a good
person nice to people you know that's
what I look for what do I look for yeah
companionship complicity or liability
and love honesty I think creativity
intelligence and a Democrat for me so
the most important is respect
the way she treats other people yeah she
has to love my family if she doesn't
laugh I like my family's game over
honestly oil tea is a big one
I mean I want somebody that's gonna be
as loyal as I am to them you know and
that you know there's there's so many
ideas on monogamy and polyamory and
stuff like that they're out there and I
don't know it's just it's one of those
things where I I just kind of prefer a
one-on-one type of relationship for me
it matters it also helps you know with
you know being a divorced dad with a
single kid and stuff like that you know
I think that it's important for him to
only see one person and to see me happy
as well so like that's yeah for me it's
brains all day I like seeing like how
smart she is because then I can have a
conversation with them and then they
could keep my interest for a long period
of time the big things I guess for
myself is finding someone that is
actually interested in helping others
and wanting to make a difference whether
that be going and volunteering with the
charity or just finding something that
they're passionate about that will
actually make a difference and help
others what I look for in a woman
is that she knows who she is and what's
greater than her in this life I choose
for just love each other
simplicity I would say are there any
deal-breakers for you ah cleanliness
orientation I have some issues you know
that's it yeah that's it I have this
adventurous personality so I like an
adventurous girl that I can say my jokes
and she'll laugh at my jokes
and and someone that I don't know it can
would like to stay with me for the rest
of my life intelligence and love and
open-mindedness are the absolute biggest
turn-on for me I have my own philosophy
about that more than what I'm looking to
now and a woman is what I can offer a
woman so because many times we said oh
I'm looking this and begin that but I
work in key and I offer as a person so
for me more important to what I'm
looking for in a woman is what can I
offer to a woman when looking for a
significant other I don't really look at
all because I think it doesn't matter
who you're with it's just like a lot of
compromise and working together to make
a relationship work and
no one wants to compromise myself
included so that's why you can be more
happy if you just stay by yourself
what's up guys my name is Raya and I'm
the owner of this channel I'm also the
person behind the camera and I thought
I'd take a minute to thank all the
subscribers I gained so far and maybe
ask new years to hit the subscribe
button if you liked this episode or if
you're a fan of my channel in general I
mean a lot thank you